Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie!
is going to be my Arrow episode 12 episode
13 trailer video.
Just careful for spoilers from episode 12
you haven't seen it yet.
There's a big Iron Man reveal moment, that
they teased at the end of the episode Oliver
is going to have to have his moment where
he just comes out in public and says I am
the green arrow.
So just keep your eyes peeled on the horizon
for something like that that seems to be what
their foreshadowing, but there's a new round
of the flash ring giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
What I'm going to do because the schedule
for all the TV shows is a little different
next week all explained that at the end of
this, but the deal with the trailer for the
next episode is sort of a follow-up on the
idea of wild dog's Backstory the idea he's
so gun crazy in the vigilante character so
is gonna be one of those situations where
Oliver can't solve a problem as green arrow.
Yes to do it as mayor Queen just more foreshadowing
that the two identities will become one identity
of eventually people will know him as both
Oliver Queen and the green arrow not just
so, so top 10 WTF and comic book Easter eggs
number 10 more Talia and Oliver training she's
trying to teach them going dark is actually
good for him.
It gives you better cite you see more clearly
walking in darkness she trying to get him
to become the green arrow or the hood because
that's what he was called in season one, the
thing with this is that this is all building
towards him going back to Starling city remember
it was still called starting city in the first
season, but he hasn't faced Kovar yet that's
coming up in the flashbacks in a future episode,
so Dolph Lundgren will be coming back to the
show relatively soon.
He still the big boss of the flashbacks number
nine is Oliver and Susan in present-day finally
getting it on he's moving forwards and all
aspects of his life.
But the funny thing about this is that it's
all very tongue-in-cheek because she's trying
to get information on him there still all
the Prometheus stuff going on in the background
it all the stuff that dredged up from his
past that will probably become another problem
for him in the future with the brought but,
so number seven.
Another problem comes back Quentyn is back
from rehab more quips more awkward humor more
lashing out at the thought of what happened
to Laurel what he did last year all his mistakes
getting into bed with Damien Darhk.
So wild dog tries to help them out.
They had a lot of great scenes together, and
it seems like this is who his characters going
to be for the rest of the season.
They kinda did that on the flash like Caitlin's
character was traumatized by zoom she change
going forward, even with all the flashpoint
changes all the characters are suffering from
something in dealing with it in different
ways.
Cisco lost his brother, so that kind of thing
is going on with Quentyn's character eventually
he'll find a way to move past that, but he
was never that happy of a character to begin
with these, but the first couple of seasons
trying to catch the arrow and take him down,
but number six they have this really awesome
wild dog story about how Quentyn helped him
he becomes really positive thing but I was
a little kid tagging buildings you gave me
this great speech.
But then sort of a lead into the next episode
like the trailer footage.
The way of the gun he asked him how did you
end up getting dishonorably discharged from
the military if I sent you on the good path
is like nobody's perfect.
So if you don't remember the story of how
wild dog got discharge from the military.
He was on board a ship they were interrogating
a prisoner and things were getting out of
hand wild dog shut it down disobeying a direct
order from the superior officer and it led
to him being dishonorably discharged.
So he did something bad for the right reasons
because he's a good person that's the whole
idea like they're good people but they cross
the line big time.
So next what I should think I missed the numbers
up so set number six Felicity goes super hard-core
with the Pandora data.
So this is going to get her and to some really
big trouble later on in the season.
They just tease the idea that she's crossing
into morally gray area threatening people
in a way that you would normally see her do
so she believes she's doing the right thing
seeking out justice taking down bad people
using methods that are outside of the law.
So eventually they'll be a reckoning shall
have to deal with that.
I don't think she's gonna go to prison or
anything like that but she might have to go
on the run for brief.
She is definitely going to get in some big
trouble.
Eventually, even though the way to hell is
paved with good intentions you can have some
big takedowns but it's gonna come at great
cost number five was the general escaping
captivity causing team arrow to road trip
to Russia.
It's been a long time I think it was season
two was the last actual Russia road trip episode
and he gets punched right in the face by KGBeast
the minute he shows up was great number four
I totally love all the KGBeast's scenes he
so awesome.
David Nichol you may remember him from Stargate
all of his arrow stuff is been great from
all the previous seasons it's always fun to
see them back.
So the whole deal here is that all of her
in the flashbacks is slowly coming to the
point where he has to leave the brought but
that he can go back to Starling city but KGB's
keeps telling them you don't leave that kind
of oath behind.
So through the course of the episode he sort
of re-ups with the brought but unofficially
meaning the KGBeast will come visit him eventually
in Star city you're the boss.
Now it'll be fun.
We'll have a good time.
When I come visit, so that is going to be
a really big problem for him, because if the
mayor is seen working with the brought but
people are gonna have a lot of questions reporters
like Susan Williams are good have a lot of
questions.
So just remember that for the future number
three was Diggle almost killing that guard
trying to get Intel I totally love it when
Diggle holds out and crosses the line like
I actually thought that he killed that guy
till none of the other characters said that
out loud I feel like if you kill them than
they would've acknowledge that, but in the
way that all of her speech that he got from
the black canary he passes onto the other
people about how they make each other better
people they influence each other's lives that
sort of the thing that Prometheus is throwing
in his face.
Yeah, you influence the people around you,
but that's a good thing.
So black canary gave him the speech that he
gave to everyone else that Diggle repeats
at the end where he has that OG team arrow
speech worries talking to Felicity.
You know you me Oliver we make each other
better.
So it ends up being a good thing by the end
of the episode number two was a ragman stopping
the new sacrificing his powers, so a lot of
you seem bummed that he's gonna be off the
show he'll totally come back the whole idea
is that you don't need the superpowers to
be a superhero.
So either he's going to recharge the racks
or is going to come back and be a bad ass
without them, which the second option seems
more likely just based on the way the seasons
going like everyone has something to offer
even if you're not a superhero it was a super
bummer to see them sacrifice those like he
was one of the coolest characters.
The way his power work the way he just drops
and invites, but the big number one WTF is
Susan Williams pretty much figuring out that
Oliver is the green arrow she doesn't say
it outright.
She says it's like the biggest coincidence
ever.
But she pretty much implies that she's going
to out him eventually.
That's where were headed, so that is why Oliver
is probably going to be forced with a very
Iron Man type situation at the end of that
movie where everyone's questioning Tony Stark
after that big fight with the ironmongers
questioning him who is Iron Man what's going
on what is your relationship with them and
he just throws the cars down the table and
says you know what I am Iron Man so that he
becomes both of those personas embodied in
one person it's no longer one of the other
it's the same person, no matter who you're
talking to, so it'll be really interesting
to see if that happens going into season six
what that changes about his relationship with
the city itself because is only one of two
ways that could go one Mayor Oliver Queen
stops being Mayor Oliver Queen or two everyone
embraces the idea, and it becomes super comic
book he pulling even more weirdos out of the
woodwork.
So's a great episode.
Let me know what you guys favorite moment
was all explained the video schedule next
week because there are two shows I was actually
Rod thought that all the DC shows were going
on break but Supergirl and arrow are still
new only flash and legends of tomorrow are
on break.
So I'll be posting bonus videos for DC TV
stuff like flash next week I'll just remind
people when I post that it was a great episode
I always love the road trips black canary
you see there playing with her powers just
a little bit.
The way her sonic cry works he was fun to
see her flip the truck and even though people
still be upset about all the black canary
stuff going on behind the scenes I feel like
the show is better with a black canary regardless
of how it went down for those you asking about
Prometheus stuff they'll be coming back around
that the being of the big Prometheus episode,
really soon.
Just like the B another big savitar episode
of the flash, really soon.
So, were heading into what they technically
call sweeps week that's when all the crazy
stuff really happens Stephen Amell was teasing
that a lot of big stuff is all going to be
happening all at the same time on arrow and
all the other shows two for that matter.
So it's gonna be crazy.
The next couple weeks.
Congratulations to the new flash ring giveaway
winner ninja Ned 99.
Please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details
what can happen next is I have new Spider-Man
homecoming, Iron Man he's got a new suit during
Spider-Man homecoming.
So I'll do a video for that.
So that will post Friday morning.
It's gonna be awesome while you wait for that
you can click here for my Legion episode one
video and you can click here for the trailer
for the next episode of the flash thank you
so much watching everyone thought five I'll
see you guys next video!